Well, to solve this, we convert 5000 stadia
using our normal method.
We convert it to 925 km.
Then we look at tangent of this angle,
because this would be the opposite side, and this would be the adjacent side.
Actually, what's interesting is we could also have used the sine for this problem
instead of the tangent.
The reason being that for very, very small angles
sine and tangent give you identical answers.
So, we say that the tangent of α--well, that must be the opposite over the adjacent.
Tangent always is.
925--opposite, over adjacent--150 million. That's quite a large number.
Ah! But that's right. I don't know α.
So, I actually need to do the arctangent of this number.
When I do the arctangent of 920/150,000,000,
I find that α is 0.00035 degrees.
That is a very, very small angle, so these rays really are parallel.